Oh my god, I'm so sorry!
Oh, we crash, we crash.
We're just gonna have crash... we crash, we crash.
We have crashes every 15 minutes.
That's just the way of life.
It's the Doki life.
DokiBrit has never been lucky.
I work very hard, but sometimes life just goes, fuck you.
Never been lucky in life.
I've accepted it.
I basically what I basically remade everything.
I had to remake everything.
I even deleted my old scene collection.
I deleted my fucking normal streaming collection.
Like so because I was just like, oh no, what's going on?
Because it always happens.
I don't know if this happens very often, like not very often.
But it's like random.
If I make a new scene collection, sometimes it works and sometimes it doesn't.
But it hits at like the most random moments.
And then when it hits, it crashes every 15 minutes.
Like OBS in general, it crashes every 15 minutes.
So like it's so hard to like sometimes predict when it's gonna happen.
And then like while I was setting up, it didn't hit until like when I was about to start the stream.
And then when it hit, I was like, oh fuck, okay, I'm gonna try to do the fast way.
Because usually the fast way is like a 50-50 chance for it to work.
So then I was like, okay, I'm gonna do it the fast way.
Maybe the fast way will be fine.
And then obviously we had to wait 15 minutes.
And then I was like, oh, it did not work.
The fast way did not work.
So I guess I'll just do the slow way.
But the slow way isn't guaranteed either.
It just has a higher percentage of guaranteeing.
Anyway.
To be fair, to be fair, what I'm announcing...
Oh my gosh, there's so much work that went into this.
I'm just... I don't know.
I hope I got everything...
I hope like I got everything in.
Because like I had to set up really, really fucking fast.
So like I don't even know if I set everything up properly.
I was just like, okay, everything looks... I think everything's in.
And then I just went, oh, fuck it, we bought it.
We fucking bought...
Guys, I swear, I'm gonna set my new PC today or tomorrow.
It's just there's so many things going on.
So I didn't have time to do anything.
What's happening?
That's a very good question.
I bet you guys are all very, very curious as to what this announcement's going to be.
I mean, of course, it could be anything.
I saw... I was like looking at wrong answers only.
And I saw a lot of people giving so many different answers.
Someone actually got it right.
Someone was like, wrong answer.
But then it was actually the right answer.
So it's fucking crazy.
What if you guys actually got the answer correct while we were giving wrong answer only?
So it was very interesting to see.
Hey, guys.
All right.
I mean, I could like bait you guys longer.
I could like make you guys wait even longer.
But we you guys already waited 36 minutes.
So let's do a countdown.
Let's get a drum roll, please.
Drum roll, everybody.
Ten, nine, eight, seven.
It would be so funny if I crashed this moment.
Annoying me.
This I fucking can jinx myself.
Eight, seven, six, five, four, three, two, one.
Yes, everybody.
WrestleTuber is here.
Yeah.
No, I didn't mute my mic.
I just let you guys enjoy the moment.
You know, just like absorb the moment as it's going as you see the logo.
So you might be noticing something in the backdrop that's different other than just the WrestleTuber logo.
But this whole event.
Will be sponsored by Gamersubs.
In a way where basically I didn't have to pay for anything.
So a huge shout out to Gamersubs for providing the funding for the graphics.
For the wrestling belts.
Like you hear the plural.
Belts and other goodies.
So Gamersubs is the official sponsor.
For WrestleTuber 2024.
So you guys might be wondering.
What is WrestleTuber?
But before I answer that.
I just need you guys to know.
There's so many like last minute things that happened.
Before this announcement.
That like I literally was like scrounging up the last couple of details.
Like two hours before this stream was supposed to air.
Because like there was some last minute additions.
And there was also.
There was also like some.
We were actually was gonna have a video.
To like show it and stuff.
Just like the logo.
But because there's so many last minute additions.
A video was not made in time.
And I hope the video editor is okay.
Because I was like I'm so sorry.
We have some last minute additions to be made.
And because of that.
The videos.
Video was not done in time.
But it was.
It's a really sick video.
So when it is done.
I cannot wait to show you guys.
Anyway.
Yes.
WrestleTuber.
2024.
I feel like you guys will be like.
Wanting to know.
The one thing you guys really want to know at the moment.
Is who is participating.
Let's just say.
Is.
This has to be like honestly.
One of the hardest fucking event I've ever organized.
Ever.
Because there's so many people.
From different backgrounds.
Different companies.
Either company or indie.
And like trying to coordinate.
With so many different people.
And then like trying to grab information.
And grabbing.
And grabbing like graphics and everything.
I sometimes.
I even got like graphics.
During the last five hours.
Before the stream.
I got some of the graphics.
The last five.
And then like poking people.
Be like.
Hey.
I know you wanted to join.
But like.
I really need the graphics.
Please.
Can you please send me the graphics.
And then I would like to be like.
Hey.
Thank you for joining.
But like.
I really need to know.
Like.
If you're making your wrestler.
Or like.
If a fan's making it.
And like.
I need to know.
If you're joining this section of the tournament.
Or if you're joining this part.
Please.
I really need to know.
So that I can know the reply.
I'm announcing this in five hours.
I was like.
Please.
I'm announcing this today.
And I'll be like.
Please.
I'm announcing it tomorrow.
Can you provide me the information.
And then the next day.
I'll be like.
Please.
I'm announcing it today.
Can you.
I really need the information.
I swear.
This is absolutely one of the hardest events.
I've ever organized.
Only because.
There's just so many different people.
From different backgrounds.
And trying to grab information.
Trying to grab intel.
Like.
Trying to.
Trying to grab graphics.
Trying to coordinate.
Scheduling too.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so sorry.
If you don't see some of your.
Like.
Oshi.
If you don't see your Oshi.
Or your content creator.
Like.
A content creator.
You actually really wanted to see in WrestleTuber.
Um.
That's not there.
Scheduling was so fucking hard.
And I also had to cap it too.
Because there was so much interest.
That I had to cap it.
At one point.
And then.
I had.
And then like.
We had like.
Uh.
Maybe like one or two people dropped out.
Because the scheduling wise.
For everybody was different.
And because of that.
Because there's like.
Like I said.
It's different companies.
Or like.
Indies.
And then everybody has different scheduling.
And then there's like.
Conventions going on.
There's like.
Other stuff going on.
Within that company.
So.
Because of that.
Um.
We had like.
Moments where like.
Uh.
Maybe like.
Somebody dropped out.
And then.
They got like.
For the event.
Uh.
And all.
Oh my gosh.
It was.
A lot.
I need you guys to know.
This is fully.
Organized.
And prepared by.
Me only.
There's no team behind it.
Despite gamer subs is sponsoring this.
I've organized all of this myself.
Like every information.
Setting up the discord server.
Coordinating everything.
Reaching out to people.
All of this.
Was done.
By me.
And me only.
So.
I didn't want to make this like a super serious, like a very official tournament thing.
I wanted to be like a fun unifying event within the, I guess like the Western VTuber sphere.
Like this was my idea in making something like more relaxing for everybody and more so of just like a big event.
Because I feel like a lot of things that we lack in the Western VTuber side is an event that basically unites different VTubers from different backgrounds, different areas, like company or an indie.
Because that's what we see in Japan.
We have like Shibuya Hal organizing a lot of these types of events.
We have Crazy Raccoon.
We have Vault Room as well in Japan.
But I feel like in the Western side, in the English VTuber sphere, we don't even, we don't really have stuff like this.
And this was actually something I've been planning on doing.
It was in my roadmap actually.
This was actually like in my roadmap when it came to like where I wanted to go.
When it came to organizing like events and stuff like that.
And so like this would be the very first time I'm doing something like this.
Doing something like this regarding having a big event that doesn't require any skill.
So like anybody can join.
And like anybody can join.
Anybody can...
Because all of this is gonna be WrestleTuber.
For those who don't know WrestleTuber, you might remember a previous previous version of WrestleTuber.
And this is a new version of this event.
And this is practically a spiritual successor of that event.
And it will be run on the WWE 2K24 edition of the game.
And basically VTubers, this is primarily for VTubers from different companies or not company, you know, indies.
Coming together to to be at during the interviews in the pre and post interview.
And then they're...
And then they'll have wrestlers that they're gonna embody.
But it'll be CPU controlled.
But they will be there.
A lot of these...
All these VTubers that are participating will be here.
And the broadcast staff is actually a bunch of VTubers from different places.
So, you know, we'll have like maybe like some VTubers VTubers in the broadcast staff that are both company.
And indie.
And also, like I said, there will be...
Every participant in WrestleTuber will receive a little small care package to thank them for participating.
And to thank them for like, you know, joining this event.
Just because like, you know, they're giving up their very own time to participate in this.
There's like nobody's getting paid.
Other than the broadcast staff because I promised them.
Because I felt like, you know, since the main broadcast is on my channel.
I told the broadcast staff like any amount...
Any of the donations.
The Super Chats that come in during the event will be split between the broadcast staff.
Just because it's fair.
And I might put in a little extra as well.
Because I feel like, you know, they're giving up their time to be there to cast.
To participate as the announcer.
To do the interview and stuff like that.
So, I'll be giving them some of the earnings from the event.
Anyway, the rules!
One of the things you guys might be wondering.
The rules!
Basically, I talked about the rules a little bit already.
So, let me just reiterate some of it.
Alright, let me...
Rules!
So, the official hashtag!
As you guys all saw.
Let me shimmy over here.
There you go.
Let me shimmy over.
So, the official hashtag is WrestleTuber2024.
So, you can use this hashtag.
To submit your wrestlers, illustrations, and Latwee!
The event will be held on May 25th and 26th.
So, Saturday and Sunday.
If you're in NA.
Saturday and Sunday at 4pm PST.
There will also be...
This is going to be a new addition.
But show matches.
So, for those who couldn't...
For some of the VTubers, obviously, they couldn't commit their full time.
Because, you know, we don't know when they're going to be eliminated.
Like, that is the whole randomness of this whole event.
We don't know when they're going to be eliminated.
So, we gave an option for the participants.
To basically...
We gave an option for the participants.
To basically decide if they want to show up at the show matches.
Which will be in the beginning of each day.
And each of those participants that chose the show match.
Will only have to participate for one match.
And it will be like, maybe cage matches.
Or tag team.
And we don't...
It will be announced during the event.
The main broadcast.
So, that will be like a surprise for the audience.
As to what the show match is going to be.
So, there is two formats for this.
Tournament run.
Obviously, it's like the full on tournament structure.
So, obviously, you know.
They go until they're eliminated.
And that is why it runs for two days.
Because it is very long.
I originally had a hard cap.
But then like we got beyond the hard cap.
So...
So, it ended up not being a hard cap anymore.
Because I...
Because there is some last minute additions in there.
And I was like, fuck it.
Let them in.
Anyway, as I said before.
The wrestlers will be CPU controlled.
But all participants will be there.
For interviews and or broadcast staff.
So, until they're eliminated type deal.
So, they will be like showing up on stream.
Doing the interviews.
And like roasting each other.
All of that stuff.
So, they will be there in some way.
Main broadcast will be on this channel.
But some participants will stream their own wrestling creation.
Before the event.
So, some of them will be there.
And some of them have decided to...
Have chosen to create their own wrestler.
And they will be making that wrestler themselves.
On the stream for the fans to watch.
And like I said before.
This will be an event that unites VTubers from different backgrounds.
Whether indie or company.
And represent the spirit of VTubing.
Because like I wanted to do an event.
I feel like we are very lacking this in the western VTuber side.
There's a lot of events that combines like VTubing and like fleshies together.
But like there's not a lot of event.
That combines like VTubing from different companies.
Or indies.
Together to participate in something big.
A great fun event.
And this was something I wanted to do.
And we see a lot of that in Japan.
But we don't really see that much in like the western side.
And that was like my goal in doing this.
Anyway guys.
Before I show the second rules page.
I feel like a lot of guys want to know.
Who are on the teams.
When I show you guys the teams.
Who are always on a team.
Sorry.
The participating members.
So there's actually two slides.
To the participating members.
But I'll show the first slide.
I'll be showing the first slide first.
Obviously.
Because there was a lot of them.
I think we have 29 people.
29 participants in total.
Obviously like there was originally a super.
There was originally a super hard cap.
But it ended up going beyond that.
So that's why we had 29 in the end.
But not all 29 wrestlers will be doing the tournament structure.
Some of them will be doing the tournament structure.
Some of them will be in show matches.
So that's why you must be like 29.
That's not even enough for the tournament.
But that's because not all 29 of them.
Are going to be in the tournament.
Some of them are just going to be participating in the show match.
And like I said earlier.
If you don't see your Oshii.
If you don't see your VTuber.
I'm really sorry.
There was a lot of interest.
And at that point.
I also didn't want to have too many from one sector.
So like.
And obviously.
Some obviously in other areas.
There might not be a lot of interest was there.
Regarding that.
So there was a lot of interest in certain companies.
And there was a lot of interest within the indie sphere.
But I tried to balance it.
As best as I could.
And then obviously there were moments where like.
Some of the companies had their own events.
During this time.
Or like during that date.
And because of that.
They weren't able to participate.
Some VTubers that wanted to participate.
Couldn't participate.
Due to the overlap in the schedule.
So within like.
Either company wise.
Or just like within their own individual schedule.
Anyway.
Teams time.
It's teams time.
Wow.
Alright.
So this is slide number one.
I need you guys to know.
Like I said.
I reached out.
To a bunch of companies.
Because I really wanted to.
I reached out to a bunch of companies.
And I said like.
Okay there is a limit to how many.
Per company can send.
And obviously.
I really wanted to reach out to.
Like xprismproject.
To participate in this.
In this event.
Because of everything that happened.
So I wanted to.
So I reached out to one of the members.
In xprismproject.
And asked if they wanted to be in.
In WrestleTuber.
I'm really happy to have.
There was actually a lot of interest.
But unfortunately we had to cap it.
As I said.
Because I didn't want to have.
Spread it out more evenly.
Amongst the.
Amongst the participants.
Regarding like which.
Which.
Like how many.
Can each company send.
So there was a hard limit.
For each company.
So like I said.
There are the participants in xprismproject.
Nia.
Sarah.
Emma.
Luto.
Asteria.
And Non.
And then in vshowjo.
We have Xentreya.
For the indies.
We have Sayu.
Fillion.
Buffpuff.
Me.
ShyLily.
Limeu.
Merryweather.
Snuffy.
And Neurosama.
So this is.
There's a slide two guys.
There's a slide two.
Because we have 29.
And I got what's in slide two.
Okay.
I'm like even I'm anxious.
Even I'm fucking anxious.
On slide two.
But anyway.
Here is slide two.
So we have Idol EN.
FaZe Connect.
And Holostars.
Participating.
And I need you guys to know.
Axel.
I was talking to Axel.
Holostars was actually the last minute edition.
They joined the server.
I think three days ago.
And I had to.
Not redo everything.
But I had to scrounge up a lot of stuff.
So.
Huge shout out to Axel.
For helping me with this.
Because I asked him.
I'm organizing WrestleTuber.
Here are the details of WrestleTuber.
I was wondering if you guys are interested.
So.
Obviously you guys don't have to join.
It's just a little fun thing I'm doing.
But there's going to be a lot of people from different areas.
In B-Tubing.
And then.
Axel got back to me and was like.
Oh my gosh.
So many of the boys are interested.
And I was like.
Yeah.
Bring people to join in.
And then.
So anyway.
Holostars was actually.
The last minute entry.
Into WrestleTuber.
And so we have a lot of people.
After the last Holostars member got into the server.
I was like.
Alright.
We're capping.
I was like.
Okay.
We are.
We gotta hard cap this now.
So.
But yes.
It was.
So we have Holostars.
We have.
Axel.
Haka.
Beto.
Gerard.
Octavia.
Goldbullet.
And Shinri from Holostars.
In Idol EN.
We have Juna.
Fuyo.
Kai.
And Rin.
And finally.
In FaZe Connect.
We have Saya and Remilia.
So these are.
The 29 participants.
That will be participating.
In WrestleTuber.
Like I said before.
I'm really sorry.
We don't see.
Either Oshii or VTuber.
We really wanted to be in WrestleTuber.
It was very hard to like.
It was very hard.
To like.
Limit participants.
As well as like.
When we came to sending out invites and stuff.
At one point we sent out invites.
To certain VTubers.
But.
Because they were very busy.
They weren't able to reply back in time.
Or like the invite got lost.
So there were some.
There was also some VTubers.
That originally.
Were able to participate.
But because we had to change the date.
Last minute.
We had some VTubers.
That couldn't participate.
Due to the change of the date.
So.
And of course.
There was also like.
Obviously.
We had limited spots.
And because of that.
We had to.
Well I had to.
Because like.
I'm the sole organizer.
I am.
I am the sole organizer.
So I.
Made the decision.
With myself.
The board.
Which is myself.
That.
Regarding like.
Who can.
And like.
When.
Who to invite.
And like.
Oh what do we do with this.
The board.
As in me.
And me only.
The Doki board.
I am the senate.
Anyway.
Now you guys are wondering.
Who is on.
The broadcast staff.
So on the broadcast staff.
We have.
The interviewer.
Will be Juna.
Juna Unagi from Idol EN.
The announcer.
Will be Sayu.
The casters.
Will be me.
Snuffy.
Octavio.
And Gold Bullet.
So that is.
The broadcast staff team.
For the 25th.
And the 26th.
I'm so sorry.
I'm like blocking you.
Here is.
Here is the broadcast staff.
Just so you guys know.
For the casters.
We are going to be like.
All of us are just going to be on the casting table.
The reason why the casting table.
Is.
There is a lot of people in the casting.
Broadcasting table.
Is so that we can.
Basically mix and match in between.
So because of that.
It allows us to like.
We don't have like.
One.
Two.
Like all of us don't have the fucking cast.
All the way through.
We can take breaks in between.
And like mix and match.
The combinations.
Of the casters.
So like.
And so like.
It allows us to rest a bit in between.
And take breaks.
Because that was like one of the things I realized.
That having a small pool of casters.
Is not really like the best.
Because like what if we want to take a break.
And it's very long.
The thing is this is a very.
This is going to be a very long event.
Due to how many participants there are.
So.
So it's good to be able to mix and match the casters.
Because in the end.
I remember I had like set casters for like certain days.
But for this one.
We're going to be mixing in between.
It's not going to be mixed every match or so.
Like maybe like this combination will do like.
Three to four.
Like two.
Three to four matches.
And then you know.
And then like later on.
We go in with a new combination.
For three to four matches.
And that is how it's going to be.
Also finally.
Credits.
We have.
This might be a very familiar team.
Because I love working with these people.
When I do like projects and events.
I tend to work with the same people.
Because they know what I like.
They know what I want.
And I know they do a really good job.
So like I said.
The logo was done by.
SSSugarType.
You see here the WrestleTuber.
The belt will be designed.
By Melly.
We will be showing you guys the design of the belt.
At a later stage.
Of the.
Like when it gets closer.
To the event.
When it gets closer to the event.
The belt design will be shown.
There will be multiple belts.
Why multiple?
Because the show matches.
Will also be sent a belt.
So the winners of the show matches.
Will get their own belt as well.
As well as the tournament.
And like I said.
Everybody that participates.
Will get like a little gift.
And souvenir from me.
To thank them for participating.
So everybody gets something.
And GamerSubs.
Will be sponsoring all of this.
So GamerSubs is paying for all the gifts.
As well as the belts.
The graphics.
Basically anything that.
That needs to be paid.
For this event.
Is paid for by GamerSubs.
So huge shout out to them.
Because like it's a lot of stuff.
It's actually crazy.
The amount of support.
For my very first.
Big event.
And finally.
OniPilot.
For designing all the graphics.
That you see here.
For WrestleTuber.
Yay!
Alright.
Rules.
It's not over yet guys.
It's not over yet.
Because we still have the matchups that we have to do.
The brackets scenario.
And the rules 2 and 3.
Almost forgot to show you guys.
Rules 2 and 3.
Alright.
Where's rules 2?
Alright rules 2.
Uh.
Wrestlers will be created.
In WWE 2K24.
The deadline.
For the wrestler submission.
Will be May 24th.
So it's the day before the event.
Um.
It's for both the VTubers that are creating the wrestlers.
And for the fan submissions.
So just remember.
Like uh.
If you're making.
I will be giving a list of the VTubers.
That will be using your fan submission wrestler.
Uh.
And the deadline will be May 24th.
The wrestlers.
Have to be male.
So that they can all wrestle each other.
In the tournament.
So.
They have to be male.
Just cause like that's the only way.
There's no like in the tournament structure.
You can't put like female male wrestlers together.
So we have to decide.
Like it has to be all male.
Uh for stats.
Whoa!
Sorry I forgot to lock myself in.
For.
For stats.
Please have the attributes.
Have an overall range.
Of 85.
It has to be 85.
It can't be 84.
It can't be 86.
It has to be 85.
So when you're doing all your stats configuration.
85.
Has to be the overall stat.
When uploading your wrestler.
Please use these tags.
WrestleTuber2024.
VTubers.
VTWWE.
And like I said.
WWE 2K24.
This is the game that we will be using.
For the tournament structure.
We will be using the steam version.
With all the DLC.
You don't have to have the DLC.
If you're creating your wrestler.
But like if you have the DLC.
It's just more customization.
So like I'll be using the DLC.
For those who are using the DLC.
Just in case like you know.
Like if I don't have it.
We won't be able to download the wrestler.
So I'll be using all the DLC.
So you can go wild with your customization.
Finally.
When you're customizing your wrestler.
Don't worry I will be posting the rules.
On Twitter later.
So do not worry if you're like.
Oh my god.
I can't write all this down.
I'm so impatient.
What am I gonna do?
It's way too much information.
Oh my god.
I can't write this down in time.
These are the things.
You need to customize.
The streamers that are making their wrestler.
Will also know that these.
I set up a guide.
I made like a step by step guide.
For everybody on how to customize.
And stuff for.
Well not for you guys.
I assume you guys already know.
But like a lot of the people that joined this.
They haven't played WWE 2K24 yet.
So like they didn't know.
Like how to create their custom wrestler.
So I basically like wrote a.
Step by step guide for everybody.
In the server.
Regarding like.
How to do this.
Anyway.
Uniformly customize the superstar.
Entrance.
Victory.
And moveset.
Video is not required.
It's not mandatory.
But if you do it.
It'll be funny.
Because like you can put any video in the backdrop.
Obviously.
It has to be like if you're gonna do a video in the backdrop.
Please make it TOS friendly.
Especially the fan submission.
As long.
As it's TOS friendly.
It's fine.
That's all I asked for it.
Now.
Rules number 3.
Who will be creating their wrestler on stream.
And who will be using.
Fan submitted wrestlers.
Rules 3.
Alright.
So these are the people.
That will be making their wrestler on stream.
So you might be seeing.
You might notice that I also gave like.
2 weeks leeway this time around.
Instead of 1 week.
Because I felt like.
1 week was too short.
1 week was.
Honestly.
Way too short.
So.
That's why like people who are making their own wrestler.
They can have.
It's easier to schedule.
For everybody.
So.
So we gave everyone 2 weeks.
To create their own wrestler.
So here are the people that are making it on stream.
Nana, Zentreya, Nia, Rin, Fuyo.
Luto, Kai.
And then.
Beto, Gerard, Romelia, Nan, Lymu, Shinri, Sarah, Octavio, and Meriwether.
These are.
You are going to be seeing streams.
Of the people making their wrestler.
On those channels.
So please feel free to visit their channels.
To see them customize.
Their very own wrestler.
Alright.
These are the participants that will be using.
Your wrestler.
Including me.
Because I don't have time to make my own.
Hahahaha.
I don't have.
I'm sorry.
As much as I would love to stream.
The wrestler creation.
With all you guys.
I'm sorry.
I don't have time.
I barely have time.
To set up my own PC.
Guys.
Hahaha.
Yorosama, Axel, Sayu, Buffbuff, Snuffy, Haka, me, Saya, ShyLily, Goldbullet, Juna, Emma, and Fillion.
These are the people that will be using.
Your wrestlers.
So if you're making a wrestler.
For us to use.
Please make wrestlers for these people.
Including me.
You can make as many as you guys want.
They will be picking the wrestler.
To represent themselves.
So like you know obviously.
They'll try and pick the one that looks the best.
Like looks.
I don't know.
Maybe someone.
Cause like I let them pick the wrestler that they want to represent them.
So maybe they'll be like.
Oh this one looks so fucking funny.
So I'll use that.
So obviously use the.
Try to.
I don't know.
Try to see what you think they would want.
Cause some of them will actually be talking on stream.
About what kind of wrestler they want to represent them.
So.
I know like Buffpuffpuffpuff Was gonna talk on stream.
About like oh what kind of wrestler she.
They wanna see.
And then.
And I know like several other streamers.
Are gonna be doing that as well.
So maybe take some notes.
And see what they decide.
They wanna see to have a wrestler.
Represent them.
Alright.
It's time.
It's fucking time.
It's match up time.
So I realized there was one thing I did miss.
Which was to let you guys know.
Who will be participating in the show matches.
And who will be participating.
In the tournament.
And actually I'll just like read out the list.
Of the show matches to you right now.
Because I didn't write it down.
I knew I forgot.
To write down something.
So.
These are people that will be only participating.
In the show matches.
As in they'll only be there.
For the beginning.
For one match.
And then they'll have to do the scheduling.
Like I said a lot of this is due to scheduling.
Like you know for some.
It's like some people are in EU.
So they couldn't stay up for too long.
Because like we don't know when this is gonna end.
So they're like oh yeah.
Like at this point.
Like they're like oh yeah.
I don't know if I can stay up for that long.
So I'll be there for the beginning.
For the show matches.
Or just like it was just like time constraints.
And scheduling.
So some of you chose the show matches.
The participants in show matches.
Will be.
Nirosama, Merryweather, Buffpuff, Goldbullet, Zentreya, And ShyLily.
We have 6 wrestlers.
That will only be there for the show matches.
Also.
Per tradition at the very end.
We will have a.
Free for all wrestling.
Free for all wrestling event.
With everybody in the end.
For like the ultimate wrestler.
So we will be include.
They might not be there.
In the call.
When this happens.
But they will be there spiritually.
Because we'll throw them in.
For the free for all.
Um.
Anyway.
It's time for the brackets.
Oh my gosh.
It's been so long since I did like announcements.
Since I did like.
Announcement streams.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'm pulling up the wheel.
One of the things that I wasn't able to make in time.
Was like.
I actually made like.
A like.
A text.
Like the text in OBS.
For everybody's names that are in the tournament.
But I didn't manage to make that in time.
I only managed to make one name.
So we're doing it live.
There will be no.
Spinning the wheel.
For.
There will be no spinning the wheel.
For the show matches.
That will be a surprise for everybody.
Um.
I guess for the wrestlers as well.
So.
So the show matches.
Wrestlers will be a surprise.
As to who is going to be matched up with who.
Because it can be anything.
It could be cage matches.
It could be tag team.
It could be literally anything.
Because there's so many different types of matches.
So.
The wheel.
It is.
Um.
Alright.
Let's spin the wheel.
Who will be the first one.
Alright.
La malicious.
Yay.
Oh my gosh.
You guys can't see.
Guys.
Sorry.
It's the transparency.
But you guys can see.
It's la malicious.
I'm sorry.
It's a little hard to see.
Because I put on the transparency.
Alright.
Ramu.
Who is la mu gonna be wrestling?
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay.
We're going to put it all the way up here too.
By the way.
La malicious.
Up here.
Alright.
Kai.
La mu versus Kai.
Let me.
God.
I wish I didn't have to.
I wish I didn't have to like fucking remake this.
I spent like 10 minutes.
Fucking putting everybody's names in.
Only for my OBS to be like no.
So now I have to rewrite everything.
That's like the worst part.
The very first.
Match.
For day one.
We're going to be.
The match orders are going to be going into this order.
So like this would be the first.
The opening.
Well not the opening match.
Because we do have.
We do have show matches.
But this would be the first match.
For the tournament.
But yes.
Indie versus Idol EN.
Alright.
Second match up.
I'm very excited for the roasting.
I gave like guidelines.
On like what to do for like roasting.
And I gave examples.
So I had like one with like Logan Paul.
And that other guy.
Like talking shit.
And so.
I had like.
I sent like examples.
I'll be like hey guys.
It would be great if you want to hype up the event.
To like post like videos.
Of like you guys roasting your match up.
And stuff you know.
Alright Emma.
We have Emma.
For the second match.
Alright duplicate.
Oh my gosh there's so many people.
This is going to take for it.
Alright we have Emma.
Who is Emma going to fight?
Alright rename this real fast.
Alright who the heck is Emma going to fight?
Remove Emma from the wheel.
Who is the dungeon boss going to fight?
Who is she going to fight?
Wait is it Fuyo?
Fuyo Cloverfield.
Wait it could be.
Oh wait no Rin.
Alright.
Dungeon boss versus.
British Prince.
We'll see who's going to win.
I think the most exciting part is seeing.
Like chat bet.
On who's going to win each match up.
That's like one of the most exciting parts I think during.
Wrestling events.
Rin Penrose.
Will be her opponent.
Finally third match.
Third match of day one.
Guys we're going to be spinning the wheel forever.
There's so many names.
On the wheel.
Gambling legally.
Because we don't lose actual money.
I swear if you guys make like actual like what is it called?
The sports bet.
Like fantasy sports bets.
Because like I noticed.
Like people do that for like esports too.
Like apex and stuff.
I will not be surprised if someone starts an underground.
Like betting pool.
For WrestleTuber.
Nanasterea.
Is the third match of the day.
Alright duplicate.
Nanasterea.
Alright.
Who is she going to fight?
Totally that's not please.
If you're going to do that please do not include me.
.
Gerard T.
Rexford.
Our first hollow stars.
.
A dino and a falling star fight together.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where the fuck is this?
Where the fuck is the tag?
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe I have to remake all of this.
.
Wait where did it go?
Guys I'm sorry.
I'm scuffed right now.
Alright Gerard versus Nanasterea.
.
The dino versus the...
Oh wait is it the asteroid?
Wait she's an asteroid too.
Wait this is Laura Ackroyd.
You're right.
.
Rematch.
History rematch.
Who will win?
.
Dinosaur versus asteroid.
Alright and then.
Next the fourth match of the day.
.
Fuyo Cloverfield.
Alright who's Fuyo gonna play against?
.
Fuyo Cloverfield.
I'm so sorry for the transparency.
.
Laura Ackroyd.
What happens to the dinos though?
Gerard survived?
How do we win?
.
What are you guys talking about?
Gerard's alive?
Clearly Gerard survived the asteroid somehow.
.
Like how else would Gerard be alive?
It's more like.
Asteria fucking finishing the job.
.
After she finds out there was a survivor.
She's back to finish the job.
No survivors.
.
He was off planet.
Alright.
.
Fuyo will be going up against Snuffy.
There's a lot of Indie versus Idol EN.
It's like whoever gets the eye.
.
Whoever wins has to get rid of the eye.
Alright.
Copy.
Duplicate.
Alright here are.
.
First matchups.
For day one.
And also.
.
But don't worry.
The next other ones are also.
.
Going to be day one as well.
Indie versus Doll.
Indie.
Oh my gosh.
How does it feel like.
.
Every time I remove more names.
It feels like there's still so many.
.
The raccoon versus the leprechaun.
Is Snuffy going to win that pot of gold?
.
Or is Fuyo going to run over.
And get a roadkill.
.
We'll find out soon on 25th.
Alright.
.
Next up.
Alright time to delete all of this.
.
Alright time.
For you guys to screenshot the current matchups.
.
Before I wipe it all.
Out of existence.
.
And you can only watch it in the rewind.
Alright wiping it out now.
.
Alright.
The next matchup.
.
And on none.
Is the first split.
.
Next matchup.
Let me Put that.
.
Down real quick.
way.
.
And on none.
Actually guys before I do it.
.
Can you guys screenshot this for me?
Real
When I post.
.
Actually no.
When I post a match.
.
I'll just Photoshop it.
That's actually easier.
.
,I feel like this is the final match.
, .
Aesthetically, you can just screenshot this for your Twitter post while you're live tweeting.
Uh...
Hahahaha!
And then, for anyone that screenshots this, I can just go like yoink and just take that screenshot and use it for my own tweet.
Uh...
Work... work smarter, not harder.
Hahahaha!
Anyway... anyway, let's put the...
Alright.
Let me just...
rename... let me copy this folder.
And then do a duplicate.
And then...
Bup bup bup bup bup bup bup bup... wait, where am I?
Okay, here we go.
Redo this.
Wait, did I duplicate all of this?
No!
Wait, am I dumb?
Wait, don't answer that chat.
Hahahaha!
We're doing it live!
Despite so many events that I've hosted, I'm somehow...
still incompetent.
It's actually...
very impressive at this point.
Alright.
Anna Nunn!
Is our first matchup in this bracket.
Next!
Who is Anna Nunn gonna be facing against?
Must tell lies.
Nya!
Oh my god!
Is... is X-Prism versus X-Prism?
Let's fucking go!
Hahahaha!
Fight!
I love you!
I love it when there's infighting and I'm not involved in just watching.
Hahahaha!
Oh my god!
At last I can just watch when the infighting starts.
And I don't have to be involved in the drama.
Hahahaha!
Fight!
Civil War!
Let's go!
Alright, what a script!
Too real!
Alright, next up in this matchup.
Aracaluto!
Wait, let me...
I can...
Put that in.
Luto is here.
Alright, next up.
Who is Luto gonna fight against?
I like how all the Holostars guys are like dodging each other at the moment.
Hahahaha!
No!
It will be Sayu versus Luto!
Alright.
Our announcer is gonna be joining the fight.
Let me fucking...
Let me change this real fast.
Boop!
Alright!
Sayu sweep!
I wonder who's gonna win between the...
Between a fucking...
Hahahaha!
Shit!
If anything, you guys roast better than me anyway.
Hahahaha!
The announcer joins the scuffle!
Seagull versus Sayu.
Say it, coward!
Whatever I say will never be as bad as what chat says.
I swear, chat is like way more creative in coming up with like roasts than me.
Cause you guys have like a group effort.
And then I'd steal your roast and then pose it off as my own roast.
And then people would be like, Wow, Doki, you're so fucking clever.
And I was like, thanks.
I came up with it myself.
Juno Nagi!
Would be the next matchup!
Wait, that's not Juno Nagi.
Give me a sec.
That is not Asteria.
Juno Nagi will be the next one.
Oh my god, it's finally getting smaller!
The wheel is finally getting smaller!
We're almost there!
Hahaha!
Way to expose yourself, Doki.
I mean, it was pretty obvious.
Hahahaha!
Juno Nagi will be fighting against Benzai Haka!
Hahaha!
A bird and an eel.
I think birds eat eels, don't they?
I mean, I guess like if Juno is like electric, maybe like she can zap Haka.
Because like birds are...
What I know from Pokemon is that birds are weak against electricity.
To be fair, everybody's weak against electricity except for like, I guess, electric eels.
Hahaha!
Wait, has anyone...
Okay.
Saying that is like technically like unethical.
Like zapping an electric eel.
But I'm just thinking like can like eels get...
Can electric eels technically get electrocuted?
And by getting electrocuted, like do they just like get...
Is it just like neutral to them?
Or like can they die from electricity?
Like that's what I...
Hahaha!
What?
Aren't you guys...
Wait, they can...
Yes as in they'll be okay?
Or yes as in they'll die?
Like I don't know.
How would you know?
How do you guys know?
Have you guys ever seen it happen?
High enough well can kill eels?
Yeah, but what...
How high is high?
Hahaha!
That's the thing.
How high is like high enough?
I'm just curious.
I'm just curious, you know?
Anyway.
Haka will be fighting a Juna.
Let me put that in.
All right.
Next up.
Another removal of the name.
It's time to spin the wheel.
Spin that wheel!
All right.
Fillion will be the last matchup for bracket two.
Welcome.
Welcome to fight club Fillion.
For legal fight club.
Hahaha!
The one you can actually talk about.
All right.
Fillion will be the last matchup for this...
Will be one of the last matchup for this bracket.
And who would Fillion be fighting?
Today?
Not today.
25th.
Sarah or Remilia?
Oh, Remilia!
Fillion will be fighting Remilia for the final matchup for bracket number two.
I think we're...
Finally, we have one last bracket, guys.
One last bracket for everybody.
Let me just put this in here.
Okay.
All right.
Fillion versus Remilia.
All right, guys.
I forgot to remove Remilia.
Let me remove.
All right.
The final seven.
One person will get to be lucky and like, I guess, like, move on without fighting anybody.
So...
One person will be very lucky and they just move on without fighting anybody.
So, whoever they are, congratulations.
There's so many.
I feel like the Holostars members are actually, like, dodging each other for a matchup within Holostars.
They're so lucky.
They actually dodged everybody.
Like, how the fuck did they do that?
All right, guys.
Take the screenshot so I can steal it later.
Take the screenshot, guys.
Nier Asamba will be in a show match.
They will not be in a tournament structure because we don't know when the tournament's going to end.
So, they get to have, like...
So, they will be showing up in the beginning of each day.
Well, not each day.
One of the days.
They'll be showing up in one of the days for the show match.
The match itself will be a surprise.
Whoever their matchup will be a surprise as well until the day of the tournament where you get to see it live.
We all was really surprised.
We were like, what?
We're late from the start.
Let's take a screenshot for bracket number two.
All right.
It's time for bracket number three.
Let me put all of this back in here.
All right.
Wheel time.
It's time to spin the wheel for the last bracket.
We're, like, sort of speedrunning this a little.
Sarah will be in the first matchup for bracket number three.
Alright, let me put Sarah in right now.
Who will Sarah play against?
Doki is dodging the wheel.
I hope I get a free pass.
Please.
Yay!
Not me!
Shinri will be fighting against Sarah!
Finally, another Hall of Stars member.
Sarah versus Shinri.
I'm dodging these fucking picks right now.
Get me that free entry.
Get me that free entry so I don't have to do anything.
The Doki skip.
Let it happen!
I don't want to fight it.
I want to fucking...
No!
It's almost there!
Okay, I'm fighting somebody.
I'm fighting... I'm fighting somebody.
It's not rigged if I'm fighting someone.
Guys, I don't even get a free pass.
It's not rigged.
Alright, who am I matching up against?
Who am I...
Doki.
Who am I matching up against?
Are you fucking serious?
Are you...
I will be fighting Axel!
The fucking matchup of the century!
I will be going up against Axel.
What the fuck is this luck?
We got...
It's over.
For who?
Who is it over for?
Who are you cheering for?
I'm literally the main event organizer!
No, finish the story.
The ultimate show.
Showdown.
Anyway, so I guess I will be fighting Axel.
Alright, give me...
Alright, finally.
It's Octavio, Zaya, and Beto.
I swear, Beto gets a fucking free pass.
I swear to God.
It's so over.
Alright.
Octavio will be the third matchup on that day.
Remove.
Alright, who will Octavio be fighting against?
Octavio, either Beto or Zaya.
And one person will get to have a free pass.
And that one person is Beto.
Finally, the last two matchups.
Octavio versus Zaya.
And Beto versus nobody.
Because he gets a free pass.
He gets the fucking lady luck blessing him today.
Alright, boom.
Alright.
But here are your brackets, guys.
Bracket three.
I don't have bracket one and two because I literally just overwrote one and two.
So like, if you want to know where bracket one and two is, feel free to...
We are eliminating a lot of Holostar members right off the bat.
Like, I don't...
How is that possible?
Because even they survive.
Even they survive here.
Like, they have to fight against each other.
So, Beto versus Beto.
You know what?
That'll be fun.
If there's more than one Beto wrestler, we'll have two Betos fighting against each other.
And then we'll see whichever Beto wins will be the Beto representative.
So...
If there's so many Beto fan wrestlers, we'll have them fight each other.
And then...
Yeah.
Beto too.
Clearly would win the tournament, maybe.
If he's lucky.
Maybe Beto too would end up sweeping everything.
Beto...
Beto too.
Alright, Beto versus Beto.
I feel like that's like the best...
Beto...
The mirror match.
Gold Bullet is...
will be in a show match.
Gold Bullet is not in the tournament.
But, they'll be there for casting.
They'll be there throughout the tournament for casting wise.
But they said that, originally they wanted to just casting.
Just to be in the show match.
Just to even out the show matches.
So...
Anyway.
Yes!
Here are all the brackets.
I don't have one and two because I overwrote it.
So if you want to know what one and two brackets were, please look at Twitter, I guess.
Or rewind this VOD if you are a VOD watcher.
Very professional, Doki.
You've been hosting and organizing events for so long and you're still just as incompetent.
I'm super hyped for this, honestly.
Let me go back to the chatting real quick.
I am very hyped for for WrestleTuber.
Again, a huge shout out to Gamersupps for providing like full-on, probably full sponsor to this event so that I don't have to pay for anything, including like the the, you know, the belts, the graphics, everything related to to this event.
I can't wait for you guys to see the video when it's done because it was actually a really sick video and I was going to play that video for the announcement.
But so many things happened last minute that we couldn't get the video done in time.
And I was like, I was like, I'm so sorry.
I'm really sorry.
I was like, I would be like, hey, like, I'm so sorry to my editor.
I'll be like, oh, my God, sorry.
This is a last minute addition.
Here you go.
By the way, Octavia is going to be a caster.
This is very last minute.
I'm so sorry.
And then literally like two or three hours later, I'll be like, I'm so sorry.
There's another last minute addition.
Here it is.
Here's the here's the graphic.
I'm so sorry.
Here's here's another thing I have to add.
And and then and then like and then I'll be like, I'm just I swear this is it.
This is these are everybody.
It's it's a hard cap for real this time.
So I really apologize to the editor.
And I'm really sorry that we couldn't get the video done.
But when you guys see the video, it's so cool.
It's so fucking cool.
And I'll be posting all the rules, the brackets, all the information regarding WrestleTuber on on Twitter.
All the information will be there.
And the guidelines.
The rules on how to make your wrestler for the people that will be using your wrestler to represent them.
And again, a huge thank you to all the participants.
They are giving their own time to participate in this event.
Like this was a very ambitious project for me.
One of the hardest things I've ever organized solely by myself, by the way.
There was no outside management.
My management team did not help me organize this because I chose to do this myself.
They offered.
But because I felt like I wanted this to be more less, I wanted to be less serious.
And by not having like management there, it gives off a more carefree vibe, a more carefree vibe, a less serious, like try hard thing.
We're all just there to make memories and enjoy an event together.
So like everything was done solely by me when it comes to organizing all of this.
And reaching out to people and and inviting them to participate.
Like I said, a huge shout out to everybody for saying yes to participating in this and for joining the server and for willing to give their own time because this event lasts a very long time because we all know how long it took last time.
So
so like it's understandable that like super like that, like people were like, oh, I don't know because it was a very long event.
And I originally had a hard cap for less participants.
But then that hard cap became a softer cap.
And then and then later on became a hard cap because I was like, oh, man, that's that was long.
That's a lot of people.
I was like, yes.
A lot of people.
So please check out all the VTubers that are participating, are giving up their time to be part of this event and to just celebrate VTubing in general.
I hope by doing this, there might be more incentives for more big events similar to this where it can unite various companies.
And various Indies together, just like how we see it in Japan with like Vault Room stuff, Shibuya Hell and CR and Crazy Raccoon.
And this is basically like this basically something I want to do equivalent to that.
And I hope that this inspires more events like this in the future, not just from me, but from other but from other people that want to organize events.
As well, because I feel like, like I said, this is what we heavily lacked in the English VTubing sphere.
We have a lot of events from companies or from Indies that are just Indies or like or like VTubers and Fleshies or like within the company.
But we don't have events.
We don't really have events that unite people from different places.
And this is what I wanted to do.
This was clearly my next roadmap, something I wanted to evolve into the future with.
So, yeah.
Yeah, I
really appreciate it, guys.
I really am.
I really do appreciate you guys all showing up for this very special announcement, despite the lots of scuff in the beginning, because I am, I swear, the most unlucky bird ever when it comes to like important things that I have to do.
I swear I'm just so unlucky.
I really appreciate you guys.
Stick around, even though we had a very rough start and being super hyped for this event.
I cannot wait.
I hope everybody will have a lot of fun, both fans and the VTubers alike.
And I cannot wait to see what kind of roast they're going to do to each other.
I wonder if Benno is going to roast himself.
I just see him like looking at the mirror.
I see him looking at the mirror and being like, I'm better than you.
Hey guys, that was the announcement.
I'm going to rest now.
Next week is technically my rest week, except for Tekken.
I guess I'll just be grinding Tekken for Seijan Slam.
It's going to be a very busy time.
But I'm going to hope that next week is semi-rest week because mostly I'll just be grinding Tekken instead of doing anything else.
But I might not be streaming a lot of the Tekken thing.
I'll definitely be streaming the fucking rounds, I guess, of all the stuff that's going on, like the tournament itself.
I don't know if I'll be... maybe I'll stream like one practice match.
But who knows?
Hey guys, as always, everybody stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.